obviously the big news is uh i think
you've gone from maybe cautiously
skeptical is how i would put you uh
previously to uh to now you're a bitcoin
investor you sort of buy some bitcoin
recently you wrote a piece that you
titled revolution you basically say at
one point you say look you know you
think that this price action may prompt
a told you so type article but rather i
find the macro backdrop actually steer
me in a different direction that of
becoming a bitcoin supporter which seems
odd given that currently my notion of
the everything bubble apparently
beginning the process of playing out and
so there's kind of two components here
one is uh what is happening in in what
i'll call the macro environment with
asset prices and this big bubble and the
sell-off and and how the fed is trying
to kind of engineer a soft landing
before midterm elections et cetera and
then there's bitcoin and it's something
that you previously uh weren't
necessarily supportive of didn't hold
any uh but that's changed so walk us
through kind of the process of that
transition and also this idea that like
when presented with new information
you've changed your mind which you know
to me is a sign of intelligence and kind
of intellectual humility so just like
how has this played out as you uh as you
kind of transitioned to more of a
bitcoin investor or or supporter well
first of all full disclaimer my my
wife's been a bit cold going bold for
years okay and when i get on the bearish
side i get scolded quite a bit at home
that's part of it as well in fact i
might i told michael sayla last summer
my wife has a hundred thousand target on
and she still does you know my and you
know i've i've taken pot shots at
bitcoin and the entire craziness of of
of the acid bubble and yes i'm also data
driven
in in the data domain i've pointed that
out all last year as well is there's
just an incredible high correlation
between
equity prices and and crypto and we saw
that again in recent months it's
actually absolutely fascinating
small caps um russell peaked on november
8th bitcoin peaked on november 10th and
they've been in a 93 correlation and
guess what they both bottomed this week
so this correlation is there and i think
we have to be all cognizant of that i'm
cognizant of that as i'm flipping
positive bitcoin and i'll explain this a
little bit further here uh the first
step is to recognize when you have this
much liquidity thrown into the world
and we've just never seen this this is
absolutely bizarre what happened with
money supply with debt with uh central
bank uh balance sheet expansion that's
just absolutely it divorced what
happened during 2009 and so this
liquidity has to find a way in the
ultimate tina there's no alternative
environment
it will seek risk assets it will seek
yield there's no question about it uh
jay pal and williams from the fed they
were all very clear um they they are
aware of the risk of having
[Music]
too low rates for too long for losing
sight of their price stability mandate
and what damage it will do and the
threats it poses they are fully aware
and hence it's kind of shameful that
that they embarked on this route anyway
um but but for me so this this
correlation is still in place
and i'm cognizant of that because if i
look at the larger equity market i still
see downside risks and i still obviously
see downside risk than in crypto and in
bitcoin however okay
i see there is a big opportunity for
this correlation to shift
last year
i may get the precise number incorrect
but it was something like
more money flowed into equities
than in the previous 17 years combined
it was just an absolute insane number
everybody is long
and they piled more money into equities
household exposure to equities is even
higher than in 2000 but eventually with
everybody parked in the same space
today either everybody is right and this
party will continue forever or there is
going to be some sort of fleshing out
process and eventually
this is my position
investors will seek
a broader diversification
and this broader diversification is
coming about partially because of fed
credibility and what they have
done here my view is that you can debase
your currency only so long you can play
this free money debt expansion game only
so long you know we all come to believe
that this is all consequence free and i
freely admit this has gone much farther
than i would have expected so far
seemingly consequence-free
but i think they also recognize that
they have a major issue on their hand
they're talking about ex reducing their
balance sheet aggressively good luck
with that we have yet to see that go
through without major ramifications uh
from from this height when we have no
precedence for that so my view is the
correlation between the high correlation
that we're seeing right now is going to
decouple and
michael saylor when i talked to him last
summer and again this uh last couple
weeks
made a very good point and i mentioned
how this all reminds me of the tech
bubble in 2000 the tech bubble in 2000
this was when we also had a massive
flush into equities into unrealistic
valuations massive retail participation
everybody was flying along they were
making money things just kept going up
until it burst and and when did it burst
it burst because alan greenspan was fed
share at the time he had pushed a bunch
of liquidity ahead of y2k around 2000
because there were concerns about you
know everything will shut down on the
computers obviously it didn't happen
but he then started pulling
liquidity out
starting march april of 2000 guess what
everything fell apart right
but and what we saw obviously a lot of
these companies that were based on
unrealistic valuations got hit
some completely went out of business
others just got haircuts that lasted
literally for decades i used cisco right
but then there were also those game
changers like the apples the amazons
yeah they got
major drawdowns 90 it was absolutely
vicious but those turned out to be the
biggest
buying opportunities ever for a long
term hold companies
that had a
button on changing the paradigm
and this is where new technologies such
as blockchain are in the same category
in my view but it's not that this
technology
is going to disappear i think it's very
clear now that it has staying power
that institutional money is coming in
there's a lot of interesting
developments on it and i'm not saying
look
like in 2000 a lot of fluff disappeared
and and i expect that with crypto as
well in in general but there will be
winners there will be long-term winners
and my views that bitcoin will be one of
those key winners hence
given what's happening on the
uh the basement front the monetary
debasement front i as an investor
because i have you know
i got places to put money too and i
don't like my cash being just completely
mauled by by inflation
i'm looking for a long-term allocation
and hence this week i started
the process